one of the things that was so
spectacular about the first season was
the way that it ended and it had a
surprise that I think most obviously
most people know about now I'm always so
afraid of spoiling it in case there are
people that are gonna see this and say I
haven't watched it yet
oops I'm not right now I'm not gonna say
what it is but it was a great great
reveal at the end of the first season
which was beautifully done beautifully
engineered and all of you were in the
dark about it you didn't know about it
except you and Ted Danson's yeah yes
correct
and so you knew the whole time nobody
else knew right and what I'm curious
about is do you know where this is all
going how's make sure the creator told
you because it's such that this takes so
many fascinating twists and turns do you
know where the good place ends up I
didn't think you'd say what it was
yeah they're in New Jersey yeah I always
told and the funny thing is I got a lot
going on and I don't remember things
very well and I forgot I'm legit for God
did you really yeah so he told you where
it's going and you forgot the show this
show that is your life right now they
don't even tell you how much work there
and I he told me and last year he's like
I think that's how I'm gonna wrap it up
yeah that's the right idea and I it is
exited my brain that's good that's good
you were the right person to tell Ben
all of our secrets to everyone so he'll
never be told yeah yeah yeah he
literally told everyone the season 1
twist let months in advance he did yeah
loose lips Danson really we were friends